are there any form of protective
measures one could take before kissing a
frog that's two one is don't kiss the
Frog
the other one is dental dams I'm a
princess of Iran I'm a princess from a
small area in the northern part of India
there's still a beauty to having that
history behind the title of being a
princess Disney kind of makes the theme
that princesses have to look a certain
way they don't really do much they just
sit at home and be beautiful I work like
three jobs I'm a hustler I'm not really
big on reptiles or slimy animals
I actually I love all animals I had two
rats in college I had a pet rooster
named Bob it has never occurred to me as
a princess to kiss a frog the frog might
like lick my whole face I don't know I'm
ready to go for it yes let's do it this
is Bruce the American bullfrog he's a
male he's got large eardrums I don't
think anyone should kiss a frog there's
always a chance being a frog that he's
got salmonella and in all the rivers in
California there is Giardia I'll take
the risk all right that's Bruce
oh my god it is so big that's all the
stuff in him it's of jiggly and Joey
that's cool guts oh be there all guts
right yeah he's a good fat but we don't
talk about that he's in shape everyone
do I hold him you can put both hands
together like that
okay I'm gonna place him in your hand oh
my god is so cute he's all yours
and on the count of three lay one on him
is he gonna jump in my face I don't know
it's just staring at me I know you'll do
them this is really weird
do it do it that punishment if you don't
kiss the Frog on the lips you turn him
around
oh my god yeah you don't want to do that
he's just happy they're big smack there
we go it was sticky a little sticky um
but and wet and slimy it's weird because
his throat keeps moving up and down
oh he winked at me he did that means he
wants your phone number that was an
extremely strange experience well my
ex-boyfriend did not kiss like that but
he was very shy and motionless just like
Bruce so it's kind of the same thing the
Frog was bigger than I thought it would
be and there were just some features
that I just I didn't realize they look
like that so I thought it was in the
stick his tongue out and go for the
make-out you know and be like that wild
child but he really wasn't and it's cool
to say you've got the kiss of frog how
many people can say that honestly oh
he's got a big leg muscles yeah it does
bad I to language like Roger oh you're
so talented